joining us now talk NBA playoffs from
Bleacher Report is none of them Howard
Beck how you been Howard hey rich how
are you I'm doing great I'm doing great
I guess since we've got draft on the
mind right now before we get into the
playoffs is it
DeAndre Eaton who would be the number
one overall pick right now
late June is really a penny get to suit
I think it's too soon to say it's hard
to know and you know obviously the the
the lottery might have something to do
with it because different teams are it
this is not a year that I can gather at
least a year where you have a consensus
absolute number one you know people love
Luke Adan such Ayden's obviously a
possibility I think this may well be a
draft where it just depends on the
mindset and the evaluations of the front
office that's drafting number one and
and you know the lottery is still a few
weeks away and then obviously you don't
have to have a lottery pick to have
maybe the best player in a draft and
Utah is a perfect example of that or at
least a top lottery pick I mean what
Donovan Mitchell is doing right now
fourth-quarter point scoring machine and
a kid that in the postgame conversation
on Turner last night he couldn't even
get a word out because the crowd was
screaming and yelling I mean what it has
done in Utah has been something nothing
short of remarkable how how good do you
think this Utah team is when they move
on potentially past Oklahoma City into
some deeper waters well that's obviously
the ultimate question and it's really
really interesting rich that we've got
more than one of these to consider
because you know these are the same
questions were having about Philly this
is a fascinating year you know we get
used to the playoff pack in each
conference kind of tends to be over a
two three or four year period a little
bit static and you know if a team pops
in a team falls out but if it's young
team they're usually coming into the
seventh or eighth seed they're usually
getting smoked in the first round and
their baptism is to get in the playoffs
and get their butts kicked and then say
you know what we'd like the experience
or we we've been benefited from that
we'll come back better next year
knowing a little bit more what the
postseason is about this is different we
now have a team in the East with Philly
that
very well looks like a guess to get to
the conference finals or deeper because
the East is is kind of wide open and a
little goofy this year and to your point
about Utah and Donovan Mitchell this was
an elite defensive team for the last
couple of years they had that was their
calling card and then Gordon Hayward was
the heart of their offense and that's
ripped from them when Gordon Hayward
decides they for Boston as was his right
there was no reason to think that this
team could be back to this point this
quickly and Donovan Mitchell has been
nothing less than spectacular and
provokes we were just seeing in the
playoffs this is what he's been all
season really he's been a great
fourth-quarter guy he's been a clutch
guy he is as steady as they come you
watch him play you would never guess
that he's a rookie
at all not the way he carries himself
not not in his decision-making
he's just so polished so steady so
confident and just a great all-around
kid
besides how far can they go I mean
listen I don't think that at full
strength the rockets and warriors are
beatable by any team other than the
Rockets and the Warriors so it probably
ends in the second round as it will for
I think every team that's not the
Rockets warriors but this will still
have go down as a just a breakthrough
season for the Jazz and great things you
have to come because it's still a young
team and what would you say was the more
surprising the more surprising aspect of
last night's trash talk Joe angles on
Paul George or MIT Romney on Russell
Westbrook the more surprising I'm gonna
give to MIT how about that Ingalls
Ingalls is a little bit of a provocateur
just kind of like a you could see if I
said that mischievous look in his eyes
like that's just kind of who he is he's
going to mess with you a little bit
Engels has that aspect to him so I'm
going to say that a former you know you
know major Party presidential nominee
trash-talking an NBA MVP is probably the
more surprising yeah but then that myth
that MIT's
russell westbrook tete-a-tete well
nobody saw that one coming but it does
lead to a more I guess serious NBA
question that was thrown out there
certainly by Kenny Smith last night
Howard is that and and I saw Wilbon was
echoing the sentiments on
Twitter as well last night that Russell
Westbrook got lost in this hole I'm
gonna shut Ricky Rubio down got picked
up four fouls totally changed the tenor
of the game and and that the Oklahoma
City stars kind of get lost in in
themselves as opposed to a team effort
do you think that's a fair assessment I
think on the whole it's a fair
assessment I mean look if we're gonna
spin it in the positive direction you
could say and I think yes PN posted a
clip of this earlier this morning of
Westbrook backing up his tough talk
about shutting down Rubio where they you
know piece together a lot of his great
defensive plays on Rubio to force him to
give up the ball or deny him the ball
knocking him over everything else last
night so you could you could charitably
say that westbrook
brought the defensive effort and that
maybe that that took a toll on him
offensively I would of course counter
that by saying that this is who
Westbrook has been offensively all the
time he's always not have he doesn't
have any other gears he only has one and
it's what makes him great and it's what
makes him maddening and it is what
limits the Oklahoma City thunders
ultimate potential because if Westbrook
is going to as my my colleague Tom haver
stro tweeted earlier if he's going to be
leading them in field goal attempts but
being last among the Thunder players and
field goal percentage
that's going to lose you a lot of games
and especially in the playoffs that's a
problem so if they are one and done does
that mean Paul George is done too what
do you think I mean yeah rich the only
Paul George of course knows the answer
to that question but I mean I just think
logically you have to pull back and
think why is Paul George even in
Oklahoma he's in Oklahoma because he
wants to be in LA I think the only
reason Indiana traded in Oklahoma was
because a year after that he was going
to leave for LA he made that clear to
them so they trade him to Oklahoma and
it's not a place he sought out it's not
where he wanted to land he has said all
the right things for the most part and
he's played well there I think and had a
good season but at the end of the day
it's not where he chose to be he is a
free agent and if going playing in
Oklahoma means you know winning one
playoff game and getting knocked out
he's no better off than he was in
Indiana and in fact the Pacers have had
a better season
then he's had so you know I know one can
say definitively but I got to think that
a first-round exit
certainly pushes him hard towards
somewhere that's not Oklahoma a few more
minutes left with Bleacher Report's
howard back and you can also check out
his full 48 podcast on bleacher report
right here on the Rich Eisen show the
success of the New Orleans pelicans and
the absolute dynamic explosion of
Anthony Davis on to the playoff scene do
you think New Orleans might think that
they don't need to max contract boogie
cousins right now what do you think the
positive playoff push we've seen from
New Orleans means for the future of
cousins ya know it's a great question
and in fact coincidentally I have a
video posting on this very subject later
today on Leech report um I believe that
this is definitive proof that they
should be moving on from cousins and
it's not like it's you don't wanna
oversimplify this right like oh you know
team a is playing better without player
X and therefore they're better off we
make that mistake a lot but this is a
case where there was already a fair
amount of evidence that this pairing was
a little awkward not ideal it was a it
was a marriage of convenience he was
available so they got him he's a really
talented player so why not but this the
the results didn't bear out that that
was really going all that well and put
all that aside for a minute rich forget
the stats forget the chemistry forget
DeMarcus Cousins is kind of volatile
history just think of where he is
health-wise he's gonna be 28 this summer
coming off of an Achilles injury that
almost no NBA player ever especially at
that stage has come back and been the
same from you know there's one expert on
this I spoke with a couple months ago
who said there's about an 80% chance
that he's not the same player that he's
diminished and given the cousins also
has never exactly been renowned for his
you know fitness regimen and he's seven
feet I don't think it bodes well for a
great comeback so if he's going to be
demanding 175 million this summer or
whatever it may be and you're a team
that's already got payroll constraints
that's a massive investment to make in a
guy with all the red flags that he has
both health-wise and in his
and the fact that he was not I don't
think the ideal tag-team partner for
Anthony Davis anyway and then on top of
that yeah they've been great without him
and drew holidays turned into an all NBA
caliber guard you have your tag team now
it's Drew holiday and Anthony Davis so I
I think the wise move is to move on and
I'll be curious to see who tries to
design cousins and how much they're
willing to give you don't think the
Knicks will just fall over themselves it
would be a very Knicks move to make if
they were already way way over the cap
so that will raise them it reeks it just
reeks of loud let's not let the such
trifling matters is over the cap get in
the way of of beasting on James Dolan a
last one for you then you know the
Fountain of Youth performance in the
fourth quarter by Manu Ginobili only
delayed what we all assume is the
inevitable which is the Spurs going out
tonight in Golden State and the question
is is what about Kawhi and obviously
this is probably the end for Manu or
Tony Parker what in the world is
happening with Kawhi Leonard Howard I
wish I knew you know it because it's the
Spurs and probably also because it's
Kawhi this is you know one of these rare
instances where there's just not much to
learn I mean that there's there's so
much that is still hidden from view here
that we might not know for weeks or
months and I don't know I wish I could
shed more light on this but there
doesn't seem to be anybody in the league
who can or is willing to at the moment
but it's a very strange situation I got
to believe that sanity have ultimately
prevails there's a lot of money on the
table for Kawhi to turn down in an
extension this summer if he wanted out
the Spurs are not the kind of team that
would foolishly just trade a guy because
of some snip that they're in with them
there's plenty of incentive on both
sides to patch up whatever it is that's
you know causing this tension okay and I
can't I can't let you go without again
beasting on James Dolan again how come
we haven't heard Isiah Thomas his name
mixed in with the Knicks head coaching
search coming I think it implied at this
point you know like you don't have to
say it it's just he's just always
there somewhere now I can't I can't
imagine they're gonna go down that road
again
even though Nolan has constantly flirted
with bringing him back in one capacity
or another and it's Adam back with with
obviously on the Liberty side of things
but no I don't I don't think they're
going to be going there remember the guy
in charge right now the team president
is Steve Mills and Mills basically lost
his job you know ten years ago when ever
was because of the Isaiah Thomas a new
car Browne Sanders lawsuit so I don't
think but yeah look and and look how
much it's affected him he's now in a
position of power to choose the next
coach I mean you know hey Howard
appreciate the time appreciate it thanks
very much love following you on Twitter
and always appreciate our conversations
oh it's a pleasure rich thanks man you
got it that's national NBA columnist for
bleacher report Howard back in his 21st
season covering the Association at
Howard Beck on Twitter the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience